mystery of are there aliens are we alone
this is one of those fundamental
mysteries that I think is going to
bother us until we have systematically
explored every planet in our solar
system in every world beyond it either
found that life or ruled it out because
we want to know are we alone
[Laughter]
it was Fermi who first put it bluntly
why in a universe so full of stars we
didn't see while evidence that aliens
had colonized the solar systems as
readily as humanity has colonized every
square scrap of land on this planet in
the fact that we don't see life and
we're finding now planet after planet
after planet raises the terrifying
possibility that either life is
extraordinarily rare or really good at
killing itself off how would the
discovery of intelligent life change the
way we view our position in the universe
we see in movie after movie after movie
this transcendent moment where people
have this the universe is so much
greater than we are realization that of
course is the grand gesture way because
in all likelihood when we do first
detect intelligent life it's going to be
something so far away we can't
communicate with it we can't go visit it
the people were like no that's good and
then they're just gonna move on with
their day you know already people see
the discovery of another planet is just
another day what are the current the
most exciting efforts going on right now
in terms of hunting for any kind of
extraterrestrial life there are teams
recently a group in Japan did models
looking at what is our planet looked
like in each of its phases of evolution
when the JWST finally is able to launch
someday it may be able to look at alien
atmospheres and say there there be
things that are like trees and this
world it looks like it has a bunch of
people that pollute the same way we do
this may be the first way we discover
intelligence is through the pollution
they leave in their atmosphere well
simultaneous to all this of course has
been China's rise as a superpower how
has that how is that affected
the world's search for extraterrestrial
life
they are systematically building space
stations and looking forward to going to
the moon while on the ground they're
building great new telescopes including
the single largest radio dish in the
world this is a facility that takes the
idea of the Arecibo radio dish that
we've seen in so many movies whether it
be contact or James Bond this giant dish
in the mountains in Puerto Rico they
took that idea and scaled it up to truly
magnificent sizes and with this massive
dish what they've gained is the ability
to listen in on even fainter signals if
it's the search for radio signals though
China is so far out in the lead with
that big dish they've built I don't
think any of us can catch up right now
would it be sensible for maybe the two
nations to be working together or are we
likely to see a two horse race not a
million miles away perhaps from the
space race a few decades ago as is true
of so much of science
the scientists desperately want to work
together and often there are people
figuring out how to find backdoor ways
to do works side by side that builds
towards the same goal there's currently
federally invoked limitations here in
the United States where we aren't
allowed to share technologies including
a lot of software that we write with our
collaborators in China these are what
are referred to as ITAR regulations as
long as these governmental regulations
restricting how funding can be shared
how technology can be shared are in
place we're gonna be forced to work side
by side but not together even more
broadly than just the search for
extraterrestrial life but if there's one
thing that somebody should immediately
go and Google or look up on Twitter or
search for on a website what should
people know about right now
we're at this really curious time where
we may or may not have our fundamental
understanding of how our universe is
evolving turned over on its head back in
1998 there were discoveries made that
seemed to indicate that our universe is
accelerating apart thanks to this
entirely new thing that we don't know
how to describe that we have labeled
dark energy and in this piece of
research done by multiple teams was
based on the single concept that
exploding white dwarf stars the leftover
cores of dead stars like our Sun when
you put enough mass on them they all
explode the exact same way having more
or less the exact same amount of light
being given off allowing us to use them
to measure distances throughout our
universe well we're now getting more and
more hints then maybe that single
underlying premise wasn't true and that
maybe this revolution we had in 98 that
said no our universe is expanding apart
might get taken back and there's new
work hinting that even without that idea
that we don't understand how our
universe is expanding it gets worse
because there are hints that maybe
different parts of our universe are
expanding at different rates we don't
know who is right and who is wrong in
this current debate over fundamental
questions about how our universe evolves
but I'm betting that we're gonna settle
these questions in the next five years
and it could be even in the next five
months if we get lucky and the right
people get the right telescope time
you
you